mesdames et messieurs bonjour et
bienvenue à tam tam
alors comme on vous l'avait promis à
quelques temps ben on va faire
aujourd'hui le point sur la coupe du
monde c'est terminé maintenant nos
experts en football sont avec moi ils
vont donc donné leur verdict vont faire
leur analyse finale de l'événement mais
pour commencer on va faire une incursion
dans le monde de l'immigration plus
précisément on va essayer de démystifier
le métier de juge à l'immigration
et pour ce faire on a une ancienne
collègue de bercy qui avec nous vous
savez on dit souvent que le journalisme
mène à tout à savoir à bab une semaine à
prodige à condition d'en sortir
alors cette formule s'applique très bien
donc à reyniès vert bonjour ania alors
vous étiez ici à rci à la section arabe
journalistes et aujourd'hui vous êtes
juge à l'émigration hôpitaux juge de la
cité le bon titre d'abord juste tenter
de vous demander est ce que vous avez
dit adieu au journalisme c'est fini ça
maintenant à dieu pour le mandat de
trois ans pour lequel j'ai été nommé
juge de la citoyenneté on ne sait jamais
où la vie peut nous mener
et on peut jamais fermé la porte à
d'autres opportunités
je ne sais vraiment pas où est ce que la
vie peut mener après mon mandat
peut-être un autre mandat peut-être pas
peut-être dans le monde politique
peut-être pas donc je veux pas prévoir
des biens alors qu'on vous parlait
justement de mandat
comment est-ce qu'on devient juge à la
citoyenneté savez didier tout le monde
peut appliquer pour devenir juge
la citoyenneté s'il répond aux exigences
aux critères que le ministère mais pour
ce poste là alors il faut très près
fabre préférablement avoir des études en
droit
ce que je n'ai pas mais j'ai un diplôme
qui fait un peu l'équivalent en ski et
en journalisme
il faut avoir un background quand même
en immigration ou bien quelqu'un qui a
travaillé avec ce monde là ou pas ou pas
mais en tout cas vous dans votre cave on
a travaillé longtemps sous son mandat
j'imagine aussi c'est toujours le cas on
ne travaille que pour raconter les
histoires des immigrants de
l'immigration et tout ce qui se passe
ici au canada pour le monde entier
alors oui c'est ça il faut répondre aux
exigences et une fois le cv est accepté
on passe à l'étape de l'examen
si on passe l'examen on est retenue pour
une entrevue
si on passe l'entrevue on passe d'autres
étapes de référence de jack et lui tout
enfin sur comment faire à une personne
recommandable exactement et ensuite dans
mon cas moi le processus a pris un an et
demi un an et demi pour aboutir à
choisir à la fin dix juges de la
citoyenneté à travers le canada
et vous est attribué qu'un débris de la
seule du québec à québec au québec il ya
moi et il ya ma collègue marie sénécal
tremblay nous sommes responsables de
toute la province
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne se
déplace pas à travers le pays pour pour
faire notre rôle justement alors qu'est
ce qui vous a attiré qu'est ce qui vous
a intéressé dans ce travail là
travailler pour le fédéral ça m'a
beaucoup intérêt à tirer et ça pour
travailler aussi peu loin du mandat sur
lequel je travaillais quand j'étais à
air scellier et en tant que journaliste
finalement je travaille avec les
immigrants avec les nouveaux les
nouveaux arrivants je travaille sur leur
dossier
je communique avec eux puisque un des
rôles de juge de la citoyenneté c'est de
faire la promotion de la citoyenneté
ça fait partie ça fait partie de notre
mandat vers les conférences fait
raconter les droits et les
responsabilités à tous les citoyens et
aux nouveaux citoyens
comme je vous ai dit accorder la
citoyenneté lors des cérémonies de
citoyenneté présidé ces cérémonies là et
rappelait les gens de leur
responsabilité de leurs droits aussi
étudier les dossiers
certains dossiers bateau parce que nous
savons tous que les dossiers de
citoyenneté peuvent être peuvent entrer
dans une routine très très normal là où
le demandeur répond à toutes les
exigences et satisfait à tous oui et là
on n'a pas besoin de vous dans ce cas là
non non c'est l'agent de la citoyenneté
qui qui accepte tout de suite la demande
mais s'il s'agit d'un cas un peu plus
compliqué où beaucoup plus compliqué il
est oui il l'est il sera au bureau du
juge et le juge a le droit de faire des
audiences
et après ça il rédige sa décision
pendant soixante il a 60 jours pour
rendre sa décision
si jamais le demandeur n'est pas
satisfait de la de la décision du juge
il peut il peut contester oui oui et à
ce moment là
la décision est révisée par la cour
fédérale est ce qu'un travail on va dire
subjectif dans ses évaluations là que
vous faites ou vous avez des règles des
grilles coup vous appliquer à la lettre
et oui c'est la loi à la lettre on doit
appliquer c'est la neutralité absolue
c'est l'impartialité
le juge doit être neutre c'est ce que
j'ai appris et d'ailleurs de mon travail
en tant que journaliste j'ai toujours
appris d'être objective neutre sans
aucun ami personnel et c'est une chose à
appliquer absolument il s'appelle dure
parfois si vous avez un cas qui est
quand même en cas de compassion qui
nécessite certaines compris en chant et
que vous comme on va dire mr ah oui tout
ça peut être parfois difficile non plus
mais il faut il faut il faut savoir
qu'il faut mettre en premier la loi
suivre la loi à la lettre et ensuite
décider vraiment si c'est un cas
accepter ou à refuser mais avec des
arguments très très logique qui
répondent aux exigences de la loi aussi
parce que je peux pas faire jouer mes
sentiments là dedans
et je vous dit didier s'il ya un nom que
je connais par hasard où j'ai entendu
parler j'ai pas le droit de traiter ce
dossier là je leur ai faire un autre
juge
et ça ça fait partie du conflit
d'intérêts ça fait partie de
l'impartialité et on veut pas aller
latin voilà et justement les cas que
vous sur lesquels vous statuer cdk qui
vous sont à retirer à tout hasard ou
bien c'est déjà de toulouse où vous avez
contenir
ap toise et ce qui est beaucoup plus de
travail
maintenant avec l'histoire des bols de
kaki qui ont comme je suis aidé des
personnes qui habitent aux états unis
puis qu'est venu mais ils se sont pas
rendus à la citoyenneté encore ces gens
là doivent passer par tout le processus
des réfugiés de l'immigration du statut
de résident permanent
c'est vraiment la dernière phase qui se
rend chez le juge de la citoyenneté
c'est la phase de la citoyenneté on est
tous immigrants on sait de quoi il
s'agit c'est un long processus
alors oui moi c'est seulement ou bien
les juges de la citoyenneté en général
ils ont juste les cas de citoyens tête
quasi coma quand j'ai vécu mon la
cérémonie de citoyenneté au canada
c'était quand même un moment très
émouvant
avez vous déjà commencé à vous préparer
pour ces gens des parce que les gens
prennent ça vraiment au sérieux puis
c'est un bon moment qu'on vit quand on
devient citoyen c'est un moment
extrêmement joyeux pas comment je peux
pas vous décrire comment la joie des
gens est contagieuse je suis joyeuse
malgré moi signe hier j'ai fait ma
troisième cérémonie
et malgré le grand nombre de nouveaux
citoyens qui ont eu leur citoyenneté à
cette cérémonie là il y avait 2 176
personnes qui ont eu leur citoyenneté
hier j'étais tellement joyeuse dans la
face de chaque individu je voyais un
bonheur qui rayonnait et je pouvais pas
ne pas être heureuse ne pas recevoir ce
bonheur il ya des gens qui arrivent
devant moi à qui je donne le certificat
de citoyenneté qui me demande est ce
qu'on peut vous prendre dans nos
pratiques et les gens pensent que oui
personnellement vous avez contribué à
exactement à ce qui leur arrive cette
bonne nouvelle qui leur arrive c'est la
représentante un peu de recul le pays
doublé des impôts c'est ça exactement je
suis il y à une personne même qui est
venu prendre la photo à côté de moi qui
m'a dit merci
le canada il me regarde vers nous
mais est ce qu un juge de la citoyenneté
pour contribuer à l'expulsion de
quelques heures non non vous donnez
votre vous donnez votre verdict et puis
la suite des choses
ça va pas de vous non pas du tout nous
on refuse la citoyenneté se sait tout
mais on expulse personnes le message
certainement mon mari valentin piel va
plus tranquille parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il me voit il se met debout mais
sinon vous êtes vraiment indépendant de
toi tout l'appareil
vous êtes quand même un organisme qui
relève d'un ministère l'inusable de
l'immigration de réfugiés la citoyenneté
dont vous êtes complètement indépendante
dans votre travail oui nous sommes
d'ailleurs appelé les décideurs
indépendant nous sommes tout à fait
indépendant il ya personne qui peut
influencer nos décisions c'est vraiment
ça dépend de nous nous seuls qui se bat
l il peut y avoir aussi je pense des
raisons multiples pourquoi on refuse la
nationalité à une personne ment c'est
tous des résidants citoyenne si je
comprends oui donc un exemple comment on
peut refuser la citoyenneté est résident
permanent
si si par exemple on a parmi les données
qu'on a devant nous dans le dossier que
cette personne là n'a pas résidé au
canada n'a pas répondu à la présence
effective physique au canada pendant le
temps précis que la loi le que la loi
précise c'est vraiment principe c'est la
raison principale c'est la raison
précise norbert ore vous avez une
question aussi oui pour regardant ma
communauté sont timides
alors il est d'origine portugaise à
l'onu était donc les gens âgés ils ont
peur d'aller voir
le juge quand c'est pour poser des
questions qu'est ce que vous leur dire
pour qu'ils soient plus à l'aise
moi je peux vous dire qu'il n'y a pas
des gens qui viennent nous poser des
questions dans nos bureaux
c'est lors de la cérémonie qui a des
gens qui qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent
venir nous parler mais dans mon bureau
il n'y a pas je reçois pas des gens sauf
les gens que je convoque pour venir à
des audiences parce que leur dossier est
devant moi à part ça les gens je peux
pas leur parler
c'est à dire ils savent pas que j'existe
là dans mon bureau c'est seulement les
gens que je convoque oui quelqu'un de
très ambitieux voilà alors régnât donc
vous avez dit au début que n'est pas
impossible que vous retournez dans le
journalisme
qu'est ce qui vous manque en ce moment
votre enseigne ça précisément vraiment
cette cesser ce beau monde là ces gens
qui posent des questions très
intéressantes ces gens curieux qui
savent surtout qu'ils ont une
connaissance très très approfondie sur
tous les sujets justement aujourd'hui je
viens de recevoir une petite remarque
comme quoi quelqu'un a commenté sur une
nouvelle sur la nouvelle de ma
nomination
une personne qui a commenté qui dit ah
je comprends pas comment une speakerine
on m'appelait une speakerine pas une
journaliste commet une speakerine peut
devenir juge
alors que c'est absolument nécessaire
d'avoir un diplôme en droit
oui pour devenir juge en général c'est
ça mais c'est pas le cas pour devenir
juge de la citoyenneté
le journaliste n'est pas un une
speakerine seulement le journalisme le
journaliste et est une encyclopédie
ambulante
il ya des gens qui connaissent surtout
regardez par exemple pas l'hommage dans
l'exemple de paloma elle et koné
le sport et connaît la politique à
connaît la politique du mexique a
connaît l'amérique latine actonel canada
connaît tous enfin français parlent
l'espagnol tout donc vraiment il faut
pas l'unité
le journaliste comme un quelqu'un qu'on
écoute à la radio c'est le fun vous
parler à la radio c'est pas ça le
travail du journaliste en dit long aussi
sur la personne qui fait ce genre de
commentaire alors oui on peut aller très
très loin
alors on a une collègue aussi qui doit
être avec nous je ne sais pas si il est
là donc on va donc passer d'une collègue
ancien à une collègue actuelle toujours
régna merci beaucoup d'être venu nous
parler de votre nouvelle profession et
on est très fiers douvres merci beaucoup
à didier merci à tout le monde et merci
d'avoir reçu merci alors voilà donc
pendant que rania est en train de s'en
aller on va changer de sujet on va
parler d'un sujet qui pourrait peut-être
en surprendre plusieurs
parce que quand on parle du pôle nord et
évidemment on pense à quoi on pense tout
de suite au froid le pôle nord c'est une
raison très très froide on ne pense pas
autre chose et pourtant le bonheur peut
être aussi un lieu de tourisme un lieu
de tourisme très intéressante très
passionnant avec ses forces et ses
faiblesses
et justement pour en parler ma collègue
et lisse qu'une et là bonjour ellis
wiimotion élise s'occupe du volet
canadien de ce qu'on appelle ici le
regard sur l'arctique c'est un projet
international
bon alors vous avez fait un dossier très
élaboré très fouillée sur le tourisme
dans l'arctique a l'air d'instagram
alors ça dossier donc comme je dis qui
est très passionnant il ya beaucoup de
choses à découvrir
la première chose qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est de se dire mais qu'est ce
qu'on irait voir là bas comme touristes
dans cette partie du monde réputée pour
son froid mais maintenant on a les
touristes un petit peu de partout où
l'arctic et dans les nouvelles tout le
temps à cause de changements climatiques
les bosses et les belles images mais le
problème
atik que les gens a pas vraiment
explorer avant que le tourisme explose
par exemple on est payé comme island
seul un environnement l'environnement
dans le nom est très très très fragile
et d'une côté de pays nordiques vaut
beaucoup avoir une industrie du tourisme
dans le nord parce qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'esprit pour beaucoup d'économies donc
le tourisme c'est l'une des rares
sources de revenus en dehors des des
matières premières c'est exactement
encore mais le problème du courrier de
tourisme de masse seul un environnement
fragile et comment vont island as et les
conséquences qui les gens ne pas
vraiment prévu à l'avant alors parlons
justement de ses conséquences la caisse
qu'on commence à constater suite à cette
arrivée massive de touristes parce qu'on
parle quand même de touristes cette zone
qui a coiffé 3 304 3 100 à 300 400 mille
personnes et on reçoit beaucoup plus de
touristes par rapport à la population
locale
oui il faut dire donne tout les pays
nordiques qui sont très très fier que
les gens de partout dans le monde veut
visiter le village la communauté mais
c'est très peu peuplée dans la norme sur
maintenant par exemple tout le monde
finland le nom du canada beaucoup de
m'avoir veris langue parce que c'est
maintenant c'est une de les places le
plus populaire dans le nord pour faire
des visites mais ils voient que
maintenant il comme 10 millions de
touristes par rennais en islande mais
par exemple l'école policière ça reste
le même ils sont plus capables de faire
face le tout seul tu cela même en sus
des faits structure c'est là même toutes
les hôpitaux ou essayer de prescience le
système de santé et tout le monde par
exemple on lui dit on aime les curistes
on veut que les gens voient nos cultures
et tout ça sauf c'est un exemple et
comme au canada maintenant avec les
croisières dans l'arctique
beaucoup de gens j écoute peut être il
faut planifier un petit peu plus pour
les phlox de touristes dans nos lieux
est ce que le fait que est là
la banquise est en train de défendre est
ce que ça permet un nouveau nouvelle
forme de tourisme dans le grand nord
absolument et palau mais c'est très
important parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
place en actifs qui sont accessibles
merlin oui à cause des bateaux et tout
ça et puis aussi juste la nature est
tellement spectaculaire et avance des
possibles est allé manger ni un vidéo
d'efforts vous nous avez fait sursauter
sellin vidéo qui est en train de montrer
à côté de l'entrevue pour qu'ils vous
voyez le site que kelis a élaboré il ya
montré un petit pc quoi l'islande
en tout 10 mhz justin bieber est allé
tourner une vidéo là bas oui et comment
voit il comme dans la terre dans les
lots des glacis tout ça il faut pas
faire cela c'est interdit que partout
dans nos sites naturels en islande
il ya des pertes car didier faut pas
marcher à l'extérieur des pistes parce
que légalement est tellement fragile
ça peut jamais récupérer mais il dit
quand il ya une vidéo comme ça de justin
bieber qui comme des millions de fois
ils sont simplement impuissante à vous
parce que vous faites allusion à sa
l'impact d'instagram et de justin bieber
l'impact a eu mais c'est très petit cul
les hisser en arctique parce qu'elle est
la nature qui on voit ça nulle part
ailleurs
mais quand il ya des photos qui vont
vers il tout le monde et l'islandais du
tout le monde veut aller à la même place
pourtant la même photo d'exactement le
moment au sol des deux millions de
personnes par eni qui va exactement le
même place so c'est ça monte aussi si le
gouvernement et les pays eux-mêmes
dirige pas le tourisme
instagram va le faire par exemple pour
eux une image très très révélatrice la
de tous et de photographes qui sont
agglutinés même endroit dans la même
direction donc beau film en le maire de
la même chose il imagine que c'est de
l'érosion prom
hallucinante parce que comme vous dites
2 millions de personnes passent par le
même chemin qui sert avec 2 assure que
ça change complètement le père place et
même ici ça c'est qu'apple dans
l'islande et beaucoup de lieux de
l'autre côté qui sont extraordinaires
mais le monde veut juste prendre cette
photo parce que c'est ça qui était viré
sur instagram est encore tout le monde y
aucune casse en islande qui dit on veut
pas ça mais il faut que ça soit dirigée
ici les touristes étaient dispersés à
travers le pays serait pas un problème
le problème c'est que c'est pas le
gouvernement ou le biologiste où les
environnementalistes qui dit ok on va
bâtir cette lieu pour que l'on peut
recevoir les gens c'est intégré ami
justin bieber qui ont décidé ou vers les
gens et ça marche pas et vous excuser ce
tourisme de masse ainsi qu'en islande s
qui peut se répercuter par exemple dans
le grand nord canadien
mais c'est ça dans des chambres de
commerce dans plusieurs régions pas
juste un actif du canada mais en
finlande en suède
tout le monde regarde ça il veut la même
chose parce que pour l'économie et
l'islande et c'est ça qui est sauvé
l'économie après que le shoot and 2008
sauf que c est faux c'est une balance
que les gens recherchent mais c'est
comme jeudi et beaucoup d'aidé des
choses que je les ans je peux apprendre
l'islam mais aussi les choses qu'il faut
fait un peu attention
est ce que le gouvernement justement
parce que là on atteint allusion aux
touristes qui semble s'imposer de même
suite justement l'influencé d'instagram
ou encore justin bieber est ce que le
gouvernement est en train de prendre
quand même des des actions pour essayer
de canaliser un petit peu tout ça en
islande pas vraiment ça c'est un gros
débat dans le pays parce que c'est trop
tard c'est ça que beaucoup de monde et
c'est vraiment trop tard et puis ça
prend aussi en islande c'était quand
même petit björk la cie pour 300 milles
islandais et il faut complètement réfère
juste la façon que le pays et se
structurer
parce que c'est un pays avancé de
l'agriculture et la pêche
et oui il dit comme pour le tourisme
c'est l'économie c'est l'industrie c'est
c'est tout si toutes les dimensions
sociales
est ce que la compagnie aérienne qui
passe par l'islande ont vraiment changé
et ont contribué à ces grands
changements là absolument les nouvelles
compagnies qui passent par là pour aller
en europe et tout ça donc j'imagine que
ça ait un rôle et ça c'est très très
veulent parce que beaucoup de gens dans
d'autres pays arctiques qui veut le même
chose mais l'islande y en a une vente
âge parce que on est le seul pays
circumpolaires ou l'accessibilité on est
des dizaines de vols chaque jour on n'a
pas ça dans le nord du canada
exact ça c'est intéressant ça alors là
quand vous êtes vous avez rencontré
plein de gens
est ce que le moral de la population
compte tenu de ce qu'on va dire de ce
dilemme entre développement économique
et un pacte de tourisme
quel est le moral des gens est ce que
les gens sont plutôt contents de ce qui
arrive ou bien ils sont inquiets en
disant attention attention ce monsieur
par notre wacken à chaud je dois dire
c'est de plus frappant c'est que c'est
les gens qui travaillent dans
l'industrie du tourisme qui sont le plus
critique de ce qui arrive et ça c'est un
élément très important parce que euh il
dit c'est la nature qui attire les gens
dans notre pays
mais on est en train de détruire la
nature la nature
et puis il faut que ça arrête il fait
beaucoup de pression sur le gouvernement
ça change beaucoup en islande ces
derniers temps mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les gens qui peut
profiter de ce sont les gens qui dit il
faut mettre le frêne parce que c'est peu
durable ce qui est écrit qu'on parle de
nature and island on parle
d'environnement
quels sont les éléments les plus
fragiles qui sont peut-être les pixels
plus menacés par cette arrivée massive
de touristes c'est la végétation
parce que l'islam c'est un drôle kane
ancien s'était créé par un volcan
il ya pas beaucoup de terre alors c'est
le végétation est très très fragile ça
prend des centaines d'années de pousser
mais quand les gens qui marchent la tue
et comme juste trois mois citant les
groupes de touristes qui passe ses étés
du ps
et puis ça prend de 30 à 42
de revenir comme un peu comme avant
selon pas vraiment de tout le terreau la
végétation fascinant fascinant en tout
cas je vous conseille très fortement
d'aller sur le site de deux regards sur
l'arctique et de lire ce dossier délit
ce qui est extraordinaire l'avant
support visuel ce plan du contenu aussi
vous avez une version française avait
une version anglaise aussi est lisse
qu'une merci beaucoup je me sens
beaucoup merci merci alors voilà donc
maintenant on va terminer avec les
amateurs de foot
ellis vous pouvez rester si vous voulez
ou bien que gekko la circonstance je
peux représenter l'islande effectivement
qui était qui anime et quand même cette
coupe du monde
or au tout début alors dans ce qui était
la dernière fois on allait aux huitièmes
de finale
bon entre les huitièmes de finale et
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses se sont
se sont passés juste pour vous rappeler
un petit peu la garde et la ceni je
rappelle que par exemple si je prends je
connais pas je prenais pas tous les
matches mais si je prends le cadre du
match argentine france il n'ya que
ismaël qui aimes tu es un petit
résistant en pensant que la france
pouvait l'emporter il dit jeudi
la france va l'emporter mois que
l'argentine gagne mais ça va pas ça va
pas comme ça mais sinon il y avait quand
même un peu l'unanimité autour de la
table que l'argentine qui était sorti
quand même façon miraculeuse de son
dernier match aller l'emporter qu'elle
était galvanisé aller plus loin mais
ismaël a résisté à cette tentation là il
a pensé que la france gagnerait croatie
danemark
vous avez eu raison alors vous allez
tous me raison vous aviez pensé à la
croatie donc il ya eu pas eu de problème
à ce niveau-là brésil mexique
évidemment il mexicaine dans le groupe
donc forcément elle avait un parti pris
pour le mexique
bon hélas c'est le brésil qui est passée
belgique japon aussi dans l'art c'était
unanimité autour de la table vous tous
vous étiez du côté de la belgique du
côté de
suède suisse l'a pas quand bon le seul
qui s'était un peu qu'ils étaient allés
du côté de la suède
je pense et esmael mais tous les autres
étaient du côté de la suisse et puis
colombie colombie angleterre bon là
c'était un peu on va dire plus la
colombie qui avait qui avait les faveurs
du groupe
mais finalement c'est ce qu'on voulait
que la colombie shopping comme on dit
dans notre langue
donc finalement c'est plutôt
l'angleterre qui est passé et à la
grande production au niveau de la finale
et on a on entend parler encore de
l'espagne et du portugal l'espagne et le
portugal bon là aussi je pense qu'il y
avait une certaine division dans le
groupe
vous pensiez que le portugal allait
aller l'emporter
robert posé qui n'est pas avec nous en
ce moment n'était pas tout à fait de
votre avis mais bon en tout cas toujours
est il que l espagne qui a été éliminée
par la russie c'est ballack
alors justement justement à ça c'était
quand même au niveau des surprises en
valeur qu'on va y revenir mais d'abord
parlons de ddd vainqueur ce que vous
aviez prédit pour la finale bon nombre
tôt vous étiez plus favorable penser que
le portugal l'emporterait en finale où
le brésil mais c'était plus ça que votre
votre prédiction paloma a parlé du
brésil
j'ai eu peur le mexique robert voyait
plutôt la belgique
bon bon ismaël
pensez aussi au brésil mais avec la
france qui n'était pas très très loin
mais toujours est il que personne façon
très formel m'a vu ce qui s'est produit
alors que les amis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé d'après vous comment se fait il
qu'on soit arrivé avec ses champions que
vous ne vous voyez par vous au premier
tour au deuxième tour oui j'aimerais en
été on était surpris parce que
on croyait pas que la france allait
gagner parce que parce qu'on voulait pas
que la france gagne j'ai manqué c'est
plutôt ça mais des bons joueurs mais
c'est sur cette équipe s est lui même
est magnifique elle a dépensé et de bons
joueurs donc pourquoi pas ce que vous
voulez pas pourquoi une raison c'est que
8e dé finale qu'il allait jouer avec
l'argent tenir mon pc pensez vraiment
que c'est plus plausible voilà mais
c'est un tacle l'obstacle argentine
était infranchissable pour la france
mais deschamps aussi avait avait le
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france avait
avait pris des jeunes inconnus on les
connaissait pas on savait pas cette
équipe
il en avait rejeté d'autres des grandes
stars du du championnat d'europe donc il
s'était fait une équipe c'est les crêpes
une équipe très jeune très jeune inconnu
il m'a annoncé des baisses que ces
jeunes là peuvent aller très loin où ils
vont aller ces jeunes là finalement ça
on a vu qu'on a vu monsieur mba pécourt
et d'un bout à l'autre de la dea du
terrain on se dit que c'était le réveil
cette cct le réveil alors bon donc ça
maintenant si on parle de du parcours de
la russie le pays hôte mais ça a été une
surprise parce que moi même en voyant de
les victoires qu'ils ont eue dans le
groupe
je pensais qu'il ne serait pas allé plus
loin que le huitième de finale mais
vraiment j'étais mais mécontent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas passé parce que
vraiment ils ont tout donné
c'est une équipe qui a calmé le coeur la
tête les jambes tout sur le terrain pour
aller loin et il m'était vraiment les
plus ils ont perdu bond la plus cruelle
des façons c'est à dire aux penaltys ils
ont gagné aussi au penalty quand
l'espagne oui madame csf pour moi les
penaltys c'est vraiment
il le fasse oui bien sûr l'effectif mans
mais sa peau que j'ai qu'ils sont quand
même assez forte si elles sont obligées
d'aller se départager non mais que quand
même c'est compliqué parce que tu vois
si leur gardien de but et dans une bonne
journée
ça change tout si le gardien de but
icaunais à peu près au legends et frappe
c'est mon titre avait fait alors ses
complexes aussi parce que tu vois le
déroulement du match l'espagne contre la
russie 1 l'espagne a eu les 90% des
possessions de ballon ils ont arrivés en
35e fois dans la première demie c'est
beaucoup ils n'ont pas pu concrétiser
mais c'est vraiment la ligen ils ont eu
la possession du ballon ils ont eu le
contrôle mais n'ont pas pu marquer cinq
hommes brisés le brésil brésil belgique
une chose c'est que les pénaltys et une
geste technique
ça veut dire que ceux qui ont la bonne
technique
ils sont plus portés à faire début j'ai
eu un penalty peut être peut avoir lieu
même pendant les 90 minutes
ça veut dire que si il ya cinq pénalités
deux fois plus
c'est vraiment la technique kiki
guiboles à part ça va y aussi les
gardiens
ces deux bons gardiens c'est par une
belle gang moyen qui va défendre
peut-être qu'à ces pionnières mais ça
c'est tous des gestes techniques qu'il
faut tenir encore ça mais l'élève la
russie avait fait un geste technique 1
parlant de sa très particulier contre
l'espagne l'allemagne et puis après ils
ont pas eu pour les mêmes voix c'est à
dire si c'est aussi indépendant de
plusieurs éléments sera bien sûr ce que
j'ai aimé pas dans les penalties de la
russie qu'en dit il est éliminé
c'est un joueur qui a essayé de marquer
le penalty à peine en cas et la manquer
en ça dans une situation comme ça la
halle avec ses joueurs
si j'étais entraîneur je serai au maudit
avec lui
pour revenir sur la bonne performance de
la russie il faut pas mésestimer la
force que peut avoir un pays lorsqu'ils
organisent la part de l'afrique du sud
qui n'avait pas vraiment concrétisé en
général les pays qui organisent des
coupes du monde quelques surprises ce
filtre presse des quatre 2014 avec sam
tout à fait les baies décide quand
l'allemand 7,1 voilà ça c'est oublier
aussi bill à thouars jeholet ce qui m'a
surpris
justement de la performance de la russie
c'est le côté fugueuse qu'on peut dire
de l'équipe de la russie avaient tendu
nord on voit qu'on n'avait pas vu mais
aussi nordique s'est précisée mais très
chaleureux ces trois là n'ont pas du
tout mais c'est juste ça me fait un coup
de faire le lien avec island oui c'est
comme un peu le même phénomène prix
noisy mais chaque fois et aux petits les
petits villages en islande et chaque
fois qu'on a passé un autobus le
chauffeur est le plus grand joueur de
foot island de l'habiter ici
mais dans sa commune nouvelle une
nouvelle fuite qu'on trouve chez les
nordiques sont peut-être que quand ça va
être quand le canada va être hot du avec
le mexique et les états unis
et parlant de l'islande justement on a
quand même vu aussi que quand l'islam
jouer c'est quasiment tout le pays sont
pas très nombreux bons caf 1 mille
personnes s'est passé mais tous dans la
rue mais c'était quand même beaucoup de
bd d'atmosphère de fête d'ambiance
chaleureuse et tous les rentes est très
content puis ils ont laissé les ça ça ça
fonctionne quand on a commencé j'ai pas
compris
schopenhauer dont il chante la plupart
des gens qui vont et chantre des choses
un dernier match et puis l'islande ici
c'est comme une espèce de routine ni
comment ça sort puis le rapidement des
gars est formidable c'est très très
spécial
ça reste et pour toutes les autres
équipes donc la russie a fait très bonne
figure
et puis bon qu'en fait la figure c'est
lé penalty le var
sainté la figure justement donc
maintenant ce qu'on le pense qu'on peut
considérer comme l'arbitrage parlant de
l'arbitrage façon générale quand vous en
avez pensé jusqu'au rez quandalle de les
arbitres ils ont une qualité supérieure
chaque quatre ans on aimerait moi ce que
j'ai pas aimé c'est vraiment le vidéo
parce qu'on ne sait pas mais on ne sait
jamais quand est ce que les arbitres du
sand il va appeler pour aller voir au
camp des ce que le responsable du vidéo
va lui dire est que tu viens voir parce
que y
on a une doute ou ruy tu as pas vu une
faute c'est là que j'ai pas aimé parce
qu'il ya eu des décisions qu s'était pas
correct d'après moi des fois ils ont ils
sont allés voir le vidéo de toi ils ont
laissé le vidéo de côté il a mérité
d'aller
c'est ça que est-ce que selon vous il ya
eu des situations qui
ont influencé l'issue du match 8 euros
ce recours au final on n'aurait pas eu
l'arbitrage par vidéo
on n'aurait jamais vu la main d'al ahly
n'aurait en fait c'était un penalty les
ballons ça n'allait à la surface de
réparation bien au centre entre deux
joueurs français puis les gardiens du
croate mais transition ne l'avait pas
vue et les la réfléchi et elle a été
violent mais il n'ya pas vie l'héritier
tel homme et l'a pas vu qu'ils sont
allés à la vidéo puis l'ont vu s'il n'y
avait pas eu le vr6 tina tout était
complètement différent mais mais je
viens toujours au match que voici pas
colas et suisses souhaitent candiard eu
un penalty vraiment très planète voilà
grand et que la vita dit que non y'a
même pas les voir c'est ça peut-être
dans quatre ans il souffre ils vont
s'améliorer première pour une promesse
mais c'est bien aussi que l'arbitrage
par vidéo ne soit pas une obligation ne
soit pas systématique mais il faut aussi
parfois je pense et et que l'arbitrage
soit là comme un outil est qu'il ne
qu'il ne mange pas larbi 7 avant c'est
qu'on avait parlé dans l'émission qui a
conduit didier avant c'était
effectivement à 20 l'existence de la
vidéo pour ce genre de choses
les fous tu y étais une autre chose
parce que les habitants y étaient partie
du jeu maintenant c'est la technologie
qui est partie du jeu c'est aussi
l'alcool comme lui l'a dit n'est dans
tôt
parfois c'est à considération de la [ __ ]
aussi parce que dans les partis de
suisse suède
il n'est plus par le col et puis enrôlé
pulco lépi changer l'histoire
est-ce qu'on fait alors est ce qu'on met
toujours l'arbitrage mignot je pense que
oui c'est fait mais l'histoire c'est que
ça devrait fonctionner par exemple pour
moi comme dans le tennis l'aider comment
ce que ta foi si tu gagnes pas su alors
on pouvait demander quand les
possibilités sont finies sophie nipi
c'est la vie qui va décider mon problème
c'est surtout la ville du centre qui des
fois ils voient pas vraiment qu'il y
avait une faute
je veux savoir quand est ce que le
responsable du vidéo la peine c'est
surtout ça qui est important parce qu'on
il sent il me semble que c'est comme les
joueurs protestent que les arbitres du
son du bon hockey
oui c'est ça qu'il faut définir
lamentations il y en a quatre
possibilités seulement pour l'extension
de la vidéo c'est quand une but a été
compté pierre et assure c'est vraiment
rentrer au port kantien faute puis a été
pas coller au collet dans la surface de
réparation puis si on sait pas où on
sert on sait pas et la possibilité
d'échanger une une carte ont par exemple
eu faute
on se trompait des joueurs s'est passé
déjà c'est arrivé dans cette coupe du
monde on avait mis les cartons jaunes à
une autre personne il a on a vu la vidéo
président c'était pas lui c'est lui à la
les cas temps ça c'est bien on note que
je me rappelais pas mais c'est pas
toutes les fautes c'est pas tout les
matchs qui est vérifiée par la vidéo
bonne chose qui m'a comme un peu je sais
pas si déranger mais un peu moins
dérangé
c'est la qualité des penalties qui a eu
si je me souviens quand j'étais jeune
un penalty c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire donc évidemment parce
qu'on comptait seulement sur la vue de
l' arbitre pour décider si c'était un
penalty aussi beaucoup moins d'acteurs à
l'époque à l'époque on joue au football
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
aussi c'est à dire que les gens vont
toujours sur sur manifester la couleur
complices que ça mettrait la
interviennent après si on revient aux
vidéos
oui est ce qu'on a vu ce que neymar a
fait un moment donné qu'il a les aimait
pas toucher d'un calcul à la bouche avec
les manifs il il sa tournée tourner
tourner
est ce que la vidéo appelé l'habitant
design quote c'est c'était par c'était
parfois cible il faut qu'on lui donne
une carte mais c'est ça contactez les
mais ça c'est pas content pénal a ajouté
que ça soit parce que lui il y aurait eu
plus hier et il a même pas se marrer
c'est une grande déception est d'amener
il a quand même us
il a quand même été je dirais tous les
réseaux sociaux ont repris la rue sous
les pieds de ceux qui monde entier je
veux dire éliminer le maire at on appris
[Rires]
mais ça c'est ne pas respecter
l'adversaire idoine et dalmat et dans un
match qu'on ne respecte pas l'adversaire
on est puni lui il devait être puni
c'est ça que je regrette c'est que tout
le monde a vu le l'arbitré vidéo a vu
l'arbitré du centre a vu même
le juge de touche tout le monde a vu une
personne l'a pénalisé ça veut dire que
la prochaine fois il va répéter parce
que ledit bon j'ai fait comme ça demain
je peux faire une chose c'est ça que je
une chose que j'ai pas aimé des vidéos
c'est tout
la décision tombait deux joueurs qui
sont là sur le terrain je compare un peu
sa hockey mondial la publicité que il
arrête le le jeu publicité pas des deux
côtés dernier tour de table maintenant
au niveau 2 on va dire de vos grandes
leçons de tout ça de cet événement
réussi que ce soit en bien ou en mal en
tout cas ce que vous avez finalement
retenu un résumé de cette coupe du monde
avec mouassa blanc où je me suis
beaucoup amusé et j'ai regardé presque
tous les matches puis j'ai eu beaucoup
de plaisir je crois que c'est cette
maman moi j'aime beaucoup aussi vivement
real pendant la coupe du monde on
regarde les matches ici ou ailleurs
puis on se promène dans les rues puis
les gens sont contents qu'ils vivent des
moments ensemble donc ce que je retiens
du côté social du côté personnel aussi
donc c'est ça que je retiens de la coupe
ismaël bah une coupe du monde vraiment
plein de surprises les mastodontes qui
n'ont pas été là les grands pays
ça a commencé avec plein non
qualification de l'italie c'est ça
continuer après avec lille et puis c'est
oui donc ça montre quand même un mondial
de l'humilité tout le monde est capable
la croatie et la france une finale
inédite tout le monde est capable que
l'on ait quatre millions trois cent
mille habitants où 80 ou de 100 millions
on peut arriver en finale d'une coupe
vent c'est un beau message pour les
certitudes amateurs de football ont été
remises en question tout à fait des
bonnes certitude parce que des fois
c'est bien de mettre en avant aussi les
petites nations qui t'ont qui sont aussi
bonnes ans au club et vous avez regardé
c'est aussi un petit peu
moi j'étais en acte et l'upa
tout commence à manquer tout mais je
vais juste quand je retournais à
l'aéroport quand je retournais à
montréal c'est la même chose c'est de
voir de retour n'est sûrement rouillé
les drapeaux denis jerry de tous tout le
monde qui était là et puis c'est juste
l'ambiance même j'ai manqué le fun ii
des matches tous les jours c'est juste
l'ambiance en restant quelque chose dans
l'air qui lui fera un bond dans quatre
ans je pense que les équipes dites
petites vont être plus grande
il est grand devons être plus petit cri
ça c'est très bon pour le soc est une
autre chose c'est les commentaires que
j'écoutais à propos des équipes
bon notre équipe est là elle a bien joué
la première partie mais si elle
continuait à jouer de la même façon elle
regagne et non mais pourquoi le tag a
pas joué la deuxième partie comme la
plénière le soccer c'est ça y est c'est
à la fin du match on sait qu'ils gagnent
qui marquent plus de buts c'est pas
qu'ils jouent mieux alors que jusqu'à
ses 60 points intéressants parce que
souvent ce qu'on appelle l'évaluation du
travail l'équipe de france parlant de
l'entraîneur didier deschamps y en a qui
disent bon c'est un style qui n'est pas
très agréable qui n'est pas très beau
mais il a gagné avec avec ce style
efficace c'est un style très efficace
qui adapté à son personnel aussi donc
qu'ils étaient plus réalistes aussi
peut-être à preuve de d'intelligence que
de savoir jouer selon les circonstances
quand on part pour une compétition comme
ça c'est pour gagner
c'est pas pour jouer bien et peut-être
que deschamps rentrera dans l'histoire
non pas pour avoir gagné la coupe du
monde bien entendu mais aussi d'avoir
révélé un nouveau pelé dans le nom de
mbacké et on avait vraiment longtemps
attendu une révélation comme celle ci et
c'est peut-être aussi ça se produise les
élus que quand il était à monaco était
déjà très bon c'est pour ça que la
partie à paris saint germain il l'a
trouvé dix ans il a eu l'oeil sur lui
sur son talent est riche en plus
l'arrivée
je les écoute déjà 1 5 milliard d'euros
là c'était vraiment 5 ou 7,5 millions ce
qui risque d'augmenter
je veux ce matin il a dit qu'on le dit
que lui il cote en ce moment 185
millions voilà ça sa valeur marchande
puis pour moi oui c'est la tristesse
total la tristesse la déception je vis
dans mon quart vide jusqu'à la prochaine
coupe du monde qui ça va être très serré
de la folie parce que ça va être un
novembre au qatar au qatar 18 novembre
jusqu'au 18 décembre
mais on peut se faire plaisir en
peut-être pronostics en quoi une
victoire de l'argentine au qatar non non
ça va être pire parce que en novembre le
fouloir on peut pas se promener dans la
rue plessis justement ça va nous
ce message avait de cesse de manifester
nos joueurs alimentent au contraire on
va continuer les télés de l'été va
continuer jusqu'en novembre
bon d'accord si le changement climatique
ça continue peut-être à la vanille bonne
façon de voir les choses les amis je
vous remercie beaucoup de vous êtes
prêter à ce jeu là et d'avoir été avec
nous paloma ellis merci d'être venus non
celle dédiée je suis très content
revoilà les eaux merci beaucoup merci a
bientot au revoir à la prochaine